on parle d'une entente historique après
huit jours de négociations marathon
téhéran et les puissances mondiales se
sont entendus sur le programme nucléaire
iranien
la nouvelle a été accueillie par des
manifestations de joie dans la capitale
téhéran c'est un accord qui brise au
fond l'isolément de l'iran sur la scène
internationale en voyant d'abord les
grandes lignes teheran donc s'engage à
réduire le nombre de centrifugeuses qui
produisent de l'uranium pouvant servir à
construire une bombe atomique
leur nombre passerait de 19 milles à
6100 de plus l'iran ne construira pas de
nouvelles installations d'enrichissement
d'uranium pendant 15 ans en échange les
sanctions qui touchent l'économie l'iran
seront suspendus mais seulement quand
liront ce sera soumis à toutes les
obligations et elles pourront être
rétablis à tout moment s'il ne respecte
plus ses engagements alors je joins
yannick dumont baron à washington qui a
suivi tout ça aujourd'hui donc un accord
sur lequel barack obama avait beaucoup
misé yannick il parle aujourd'hui d'une
bonne entente d'une entente historique
bah oui effectivement imaginer ça fait
plus de dix ans que les états unis
d'autres pays voit avec méfiance le
programme nucléaire iranien parce qu'on
craint qu'en fait ce programme ne serve
à développer une arme nucléaire et l'as
lausanne on a peut-être trouvé une façon
négociée une façon de s'assurer que le
programme nucléaire iranien demain mais
qu'ils soient seulement des fins civiles
essentiellement on le met dans une boîte
pendant une dizaine d'années aujourd'hui
les états unis estiment que l'iran a
besoin de deux trois mois pour
développer une arme nucléaire mais avec
ce programme là dans une boîte
surveiller on aurait jusqu'à on aurait
besoin de 12 mois avant que l'iran
puisse développer une arme nucléaire
donc c'était repousser cet échéancier
c'était l'un des objectifs principaux
des états unis mais même l'iran dans ses
négociations semblent y trouver du bon
jeu propose d'écouter barack obama et le
ministre étrange de ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'iran
include cruising bar 2 6 2
faux dit rien et que tout ce beau monde
va se retrouver en juin d'ici là il ya
encore beaucoup de détails à régler et
comme on dit le diable souvent dans les
détails ou effectivement donc les
négociateurs ont encore beaucoup de pain
sur la planche et tout pourrait tomber à
l'eau bien sûr barack obama et les gens
la maison blanche ont aussi beaucoup de
travail à faire parce que au congrès aux
etats unis énormément d'élus qui sont
opposés à cette à ces négociations là
qui craint que l'iran fait s'en servent
pour développer quand même une arme
nucléaire donc on pourrait mettre des
bâtons dans les roues des négociations
donc barack obama doit les convaincre
d'attendre encore un peu les gens au
congrès ils ont les intérêts d'israël en
tête c'est pour ça qu'on a invité le
premier ministre d'israël benyamin
nétanyahou au congrès pour parler des
craintes il ya déjà quelques semaines
israël aujourd'hui pas convaincu pas
plus que bien des républicains à
washington d'ailleurs on parle d'une
erreur historique plutôt en devenir
n'empêche que c'est une étape quand même
qui a été franchie aujourd'hui donc à
suivre au cours des prochains mois merci
beaucoup yannick awards et pour
approfondir votre réflexion sur le sujet
je vous invite à consulter notre dossier
web vous y trouverez notamment un rappel
historique de toute cette crise